vor dem landgericht würzburg muss sich
ilka seit einem monat für die
vergewaltigung von drei frauen und
heimliche sex videos von 13 frauen
verantworten
doch jetzt hat die staatsanwaltschaft im
prozess gestoppt denn es kommt noch viel
schlimmer
sechs weitere frauen haben sich
inzwischen gemeldet ein weiteres opfer
wurde ermittelt und in schweinfurt stand
noch ein prozess wegen mehrfacher
vergewaltigung einer frau an
die in
mit acht weiteren fälle werden nun mit
den bisherigen vorwürfen verbunden
ende des jahres soll die akte dann neu
aufgerollt werden
dem lehramtsstudenten droht sogar eine
verurteilung wegen versuchten mordes
seien offenbar letztes opfer soll der
mann vor den augen von passanten am
würzburger ringpark übel malträtiert und
gewirkt haben
er hörte damit nicht mal auf als leute
ihn ansprachen eine zeugin soll er vor
seiner flucht dann auch noch zu boden
geschlagen haben bevor er festgenommen
wurde
völkerling ist vor dem landgericht
würzburg was wird dem angeklagten denn
jetzt konkret vorgeworfen
ursprünglich ging es in diesem verfahren
ja um die heimlichen sexvideos videos
von geschlechtsverkehr mit 13
partnerinnen die via kinder kennen
gelernt hatte und die vergewaltigung von
drei weiteren frauen jetzt nach einigen
prozesstagen hat der staatsanwalt die
notbremse gezogen in absprache mit dem
gericht denn durch die berichterstattung
über diesen prozess tauchten immer
weitere aussagen von frauen auf die
ebenfalls unliebsame begegnung mit
hatten woraufhin das gericht gesagt hat
auch um den frauen doppelte aussagen zu
ersparen wollen wir das ganze verfahren
zusammen gebündelt ende des jahres neu
auf du beobachtest denkprozess welchen
eindruck macht der angeklagte auftritt
bereit er seine taten in keiner weise es
liegt ja auch kein geständnis von ihm
vorher hat lediglich gesagt habe sich
bei den frauen die er heimlich gefilmt
habe mittlerweile entschuldigt
zu den vergewaltigungen sagt er das sei
einvernehmlich geschehen er sei jemand
der auf härteren sex stehe und auch die
damen insbesondere im letzten fall habe
das von ihm geradezu gewollt er hat sich
früher schon in der lokalpresse gezeigt
mit seinen tattoos tattoos hat gesagt er
habe sich auf seinen körper eine himmel
und einer hellen seite tätowieren lassen
und er hat sogar im prozess wollte er
zeugenaufrufen die sagen er habe gar
keine gewalttätige seite obwohl von den
jets gesichert worden wo er fantasiert
dass er frauen mit liquid ecstasy
wehrlos machen wolle
dummerweise ging dieser schuss nach
hinten los denn eine der frauen die er
als kronzeugin ausrufen wollte anrufen
wollte hat dann bei der polizei von
erzwungenem oralsex berichtet